DC Comics 56 seconds of locos helpful 3d
model tells us yep there's a baby in
there and it doesn't look like this
baby's in any position to be born right
now hey look it's John Carter of Krypton
he's just beneath the central hub sir
carla Gugino has heard and not see I
guess since it's a movie taking place on
a fictional foreign planet were not
allowed to question how the flying bug
thing knew where jor-el would come out
of the structure or how it knew that
he'd be forced at the last second to
make the decision to jump this word Zod
was a perfect position to stop jor-el
from doing this but just didn't can he
not call out for the rest of the troops
he left on the platform to come help him
overpower jor-el and stop this launcher
hey fifteen minutes in are we still on
Krypton yes I will find him okay
whatever you said I will find her got it
we'll find him dude I love my damn alpha
say how do these elaborate dick jokes by
the visual effects Department sneak past
the director the editor of the studio
and the MPAA finally Diane Lane is my
wife in this scene was I supposed to do
just let them die
fortunately Clark gets a lot better at
letting people die by the end of the
movie lowering this heavy vessel into
the barn basement must have required the
help of a few friends right this can't
be a total secret cannon ticket owned
metallurgist at Kansas State he said
whatever it was made from didn't even
didn't even exist on the periodic table
and that metallurgist was wowed and
amazed by the finding and told none of
his colleagues and when that day comes
gonna have to make a choice choice of
whether to stand proud in front of the
human race or not the time that you do
this however can't be when I'm about to
die in a tornado just make sure it's not
that would simply escorting this dude
out of the bar be proof that alien life
exists on earth nope this is a much
easier explanation also how did Clark do
this in secret no one heard it or saw it
how does Clark managed to snag a job at
one of the most remote top-secret
locations in all the world asshole
character tells audience he's an asshole
by refusing to shake someone's hand
cliche and did Clark decide to wait
until the day some reporter woman shows
up to go snooping the way they had him
unloading bags at the helicopter made it
seem like this wasn't his first day but
if it is his first day then we have a
scent of convenience here because it
just so happens to be Lois Lane's first
day on the site as well
Clark super hearing was so strong as a
child he had to lock himself in the
closet but he can't hear any sign that
Lois is following him and this otherwise
completely empty cave alright alright
alright alright I'm handsome see to see
you standing there having grown
okay if you want to have jor-el show up
through some magical space technology
that's okay but why is he saying things
like to see you standing there having
grown into an adult so he's actually
they're seeing Clark I mean at least
explain something possibly some
technobabble or something she and Lara
could have witnessed this wouldn't his
mom like to be able to use this
technology to also way to undercut the
power of the dead father cliche by
basically letting jor-el lived through
this avatar interact with Clark guide
him and generally be a normal father for
the rest of the movie what if a child
dreamed of becoming something other than
what society had intended for him
although isn't that the exact plot of
Gattaca you were the embodiment of that
belief kal Krypton's first natural birth
in centuries and isn't that the exact
plot of children of men of all the
worthless things this movie wastes time
showing us there can't be like a three
second explanation as to how the
Superman suit got into this ancient
scoutship
Superman is a dick to herds looking for
Kate Ross do you know him
he wants to be I have oh yeah who
doesn't know the quiet introverted
commonly named Pete Ross in this town I
figured if I turned over enough stones
you'd eventually find me I wonder how
many times Louis said that line before
she was finally right that Superman was
behind her I didn't know why I'm
listening to you you're not my dad
you're not my dad cliche apparently no
other strong winds accompany this huge
tornado also this seems to be a crazy
sunny day for tornado to form I'll get
him I'll get him no no yet another
situation where Clark could easily have
done something and the explanation would
not immediately turn to aliens get you
long to the over box while you're under
the overpass tell your mother about the
venturi effect then get your mom to
someplace other than the overpass
talk to the hand clerk let a still in
his prime and by all indications healthy
man die in peace already wasn't Clark
just at his dad's grave is that not the
same place as his boyhood home why did
he have to hitch a ride on a Lex Corp
truck from one side of Smallville to the
other did you just want to squeeze in a
Lex Luthor Easter Egg this movie has
more flashbacks the memento these high
school kids went all the way out to the
truck and tractor repair shop to pick on
Clark how did you find your way to earth
we managed to retrofit the Phantom
projector into a hyperdrive the details
of how you make something from nothing
are not important
seong taek's Lois prisoner for reasons
unknown but fortunately she has that key
they need that Superman gave her so she
can kick-start the plot again come on
Candace Lee how does jor-el know who
Louis is even if he somehow tapped into
the ship's mainframe already the Zod's
crew seemed like the kind of people who
program the names of each worthless
human prisoner they take a board into
the computer or is this projection of
jor-el's consciousness also able to read
minds honestly what's the point of even
having to die in this story again well I
guess it couldn't be a superhero movie
when on some Jesus imagery and music
could it season now I hop this is a
Superman for a new generation sponsored
by all your parents favorite brands the
craft he arrived in where is it oh come
on Martha's better than this right she
might as well as said hey check the barn
she's got the powers you might as well
use them even when completely
unnecessary wait I thought years of
soaking and Earth's Sun gave Superman
his powers as explicitly stated in the
movie but Zod and his crew were able to
jump and fly all around like they've
been living on earth as long as Clark
has no citizens of Smallville were
harmed in the making of this scene
somehow do they know that all this
throwing each other into buildings is
useless or do they just like destroying
buildings the terraforming okay so later
we find out Zod wants to make this a New
Krypton because so we can suffer through
years and pain trying to adapt like your
son has but who cares you don't be
better stronger faster than before and
these are mostly babies we're talking
about here if kal-el could do it then
surely everyone else can Zod learns to
focus the cacophony of sounds and sights
that come with superpowers in about
three seconds which is significantly
less time than it took Clark why metal
pin impression thing is to create snaky
snappy claws
why not I want to know anything else all
right everybody we're leaving only now
apparently Superman can overcome the
weakness of the Kryptonian atmosphere if
he just concentrates enough after Zod
blows up two ships with no problem he
then goes through a much longer process
in order to shoot down this aircraft and
of course allow Superman to stop it
here's more overuse of the Wilhelm
scream
is this supposed to be a funny death and
the death is a salut
and then she just stands there letting
this happen yslow is falling when
everything else is getting sucked into
the black hole and then Superman has to
fly with all his might to make sure she
doesn't get sucked into the black hole
this doesn't make any sense there are
heavy rocks and debris getting sucked
into that thing and Lois Falls like
she's heavier than all of them but I
guess there had to be a way for Superman
to save the day that did require
reversing the Earth's time or some
stupid like that
destruction porn Superman conveniently
drops off Lois right at the exact spot
where Perry and the other Daily Planet
people ended up well this isn't like the
Matrix Revolutions at all gosh there was
HBO again there's no freaking way Lois
got here that fast she was standing with
the Daily Planet crew all the way over
here remember in fact it's probably
impossible she even knows they landed
here Superman really had no choice here
if you wanted to save those humans I
mean it's not like he could have just
gouged out Zod's eyes or merely
paralyzed him by breaking his spine or
thrown him across the room and kept
fighting the fight he was winning or
used his ice breath power he somehow
didn't discover in this movie to freeze
Zod's heat ray or even saw himself also
after throwing each other into countless
buildings and taking the fight into
space and crushing satellites Superman
somehow ends it with a neck snap
metropolis wasn't built in a day but it
was fixed in a day
ah all Kryptonians were conceived in
chambers such as this there are fields
endless fields where human beings are no
longer born we are grown now who's the
true for 601 your time is up and your
paroles begun you know what that means
can you imagine how people on this
planet would react if they knew there
was someone like this out there you have
to understand most of these people are
not ready to be unplugged
Oh